was große nutella gläser bewirken
solarzellen werden deutlich effektiver
und erschreckender uno-bericht das sind
drei der fünf dem heute in den weg zum
das eigene essen so zu portionieren dass
man nicht zu viel ist das ist für viele
menschen nicht gerade einfach oft können
die menschen aber noch nicht wahr was
dafür wer 1 800 gramm glas nutella und
es gibt noch viele andere schokocreme
kaufte der bezahlt in der regel auch
weniger als bei einem kleineren glas der
einkaufen geht kennt das man schaut auf
den kilopreis und auf den 100 gramm
preis und entscheidet sich dann meistens
für das größere produkt sehr schlau
eigentlich forscher von der university
of cambridge haben die analyse von 70
eigenständigen studien gemacht und
herausgefunden was größere portionen bei
uns menschen ausrichten können also
klare antwort wer sowas da ist einfach
zu viel
also man ist mehr wenn man große mengen
auf die experten würden sich wünschen
dass das nicht passiert das häufiger
nahrungsmitteln eine produkt
größenbegrenzung bekommen also eine
produkt größenbegrenzung wenn das nicht
richtig verstanden hat warum also so
würden wir konsumenten nicht mehr dazu
verlockt werden mehr zu kaufen als wir
eigentlich brauchen bruder göbel ampel
anfang der woche stellte die uno einen
erschreckenden bericht vor flächen im
wert von mehr als 10 billionen dollar
gehen demnach der welt jedes jahr
verloren das sind in etwa zehn bis 17
prozent des gesamten jahres
bruttosozialprodukts also des kompletten
weltwirtschafts umsatzes
wenn sich an diesen zahlen nichts ändert
könnte das zu einem enormen
flüchtlingsstrom führen also noch
zusätzlich der ursprung des problems
liege unter anderem in der vergangenheit
der großstädte die menschen haben sich
früher einen ort gesucht der sie
versorgen konnte wo es also genügend
landwirtschaftlich nutzbare flächen gab
egger wie
sind und weiden aber genau diese flächen
werden jetzt nach und nach von der
bebauung der immer größer werdenden
städte eingenommen wir betonieren also
unsere fruchtbaren böden zu habt ihr
euch schon mal gefragt warum auf dem
mond solch gewaltige löcher sind und auf
der erde nicht außer den weltmeeren
vielleicht das liegt mitunter an dem
flexiblen untergrund auf der erde
kontinentalplatten beispielsweise diese
reparaturmechanismen hat der mond nicht
und das nutzen forscher jetzt für ihre
arbeit
wenn er nass ort mit dem mond
kollidierte hinterlässt er einen
riesigen krater der sich auch noch nach
milliarden von jahren nicht zurückbildet
experten können aus den bruchstücken im
krater viele informationen gewinnen
die grail mission der nasa beschäftigt
sich mit unserem mond zwei satelliten
untersuchen seit 2012 den mond mit
seinen über 1000 krater der mond bietet
den forschern eine regelrechte
spielwiese für derartige analysen denn
erst wenn sich der krater über 25
kilometer tiefe erstreckt bilden sich
die bruchstücke wieder zu einem festen
untergrund
hier herrscht nämlich eine derartig
starker druck dass die stücke nicht mehr
so frei herumliegen können sie werden
quasi zusammengeschweißt jetzt haben wir
über tiefe und sich nicht selbst
reparierende krater gesprochen aber wozu
ist das alles gut die analysen der grell
mission sollen den wissenschaftlern
aufschluss über die jungen jahre unseres
sonnensystems geben
kürzlich gab es beeindruckende bilder
von pluto zu sehen heute ein
faszinierendes bild und vor allem ist es
detailreich vom planeten crs und cs gab
es jede menge spekulationen existiert
dort eis salz oder sogar geysire keine
der vermutung konnte bisher bestätigt
werden alles was man derzeit sagen kann
ist auf cs gibt es rätselhafte
leuchtpunkte detailliert betrachten
konnte man diese aber noch nie bis jetzt
aus zwei verschiedenen belichteten
aufnahmen geschossen von der dorn sonde
setzen die experten der nasa ein
einziges bild zusammen
dem bild ist ein riesiger krater zu
sehen er ist vier kilometer tief und
misst an seiner breitesten stelle ganze
92 kilometer und in der mitte zitat dort
transformierte die bislang sichtbaren
hellen flecken in eine komplexe und
leuchtenden landschaft so marc raymond
von gpl eine vollkommen neue möglichkeit
der solarstrom erzeugung den hat die
professorin anna von coubertin moral auf
dem weltwirtschaftsgipfel in davos
vorgestellt die technologie besteht
nicht wie die üblichen solarzellen aus
einer glatten fläche sondern aus nano
millimeter kleinen galliumarsenid
stäbchen galliumarsenid ist ein
halbleiter der neben sie die ziehung
häufig zur herstellung von solarzellen
verwendet wird man kann sich die
anordnung der stäbchen wie die der
stacheln eines igels vorstellen durch
diese dreidimensionale form der
oberfläche der solarzellen steht den
sonnenstrahlen eine viel größere
bestrahlungs fläche zur verfügung folge
die effektivität könne sich gegenüber
den üblichen solarzellen weit mehr als
nur verdoppeln und das ist ein
riesenfortschritt bislang lag die
ausbeute bei etwas mehr als 20 prozent
mit der neuen technik könnte der ertrag
pro fläche solarzelle deutlich steigen
es gibt einen neuen tollen wissenschafts
kanal doktor watson
wir verabschieden uns heute von cedrick
der hierauf klick zum bisher die what's
on videos gemacht hat gibt es jetzt auf
seinem neuen kanal doktor watson oder
schneller gesprochen doktor watson oben
links oder demi findet ihr den link
genauso wie den zur app und zum blog da
auf dem i
schaut auf jeden fall mal bei cedrick
vorbei ja und jetzt noch eine frage an
euch
könntet ihr euch eine lösung zu dem
flashen flächen sport vorstellen
habt ihr eine idee wie wir menschen da
dagegen steuern können vielleicht
irgendwas mit den der bebauung machen
es scheint ziemlich unmöglich zu sein
oder vielleicht doch nicht schreibt uns
eure vorschläge in die kommentare und
bis dann bleibt dran bin ich mal sagen